welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and guardians of the galaxy director
slash amazing friend james gunn said
recently on the chaotic bird app known
as twitter.com that the new mcu series i
am groot coming to disney plus on august
10th will be a show set outside the
guardian saga which kinda got us all
thinking here in new rockstars what is
the guardian saga anyway like what makes
the guardian saga what it is well let's
dive into that question together by nerd
babies but speaking of sagas that take
place in a galaxy far far away do not
forget to pick up our newest latest
obsession shirt inspired by obi-wan
kenobi it's super dope but it's not
gonna last forever so go to new
rockstarsmerch.com to pick one up today
alright so details on the new i am groot
series may be a little bit few and far
between for now but what we do know is
that it will be an animated series that
centers around a baby groot presumably
during a time period either a little bit
before or after the events of guardians
of the galaxy volume 2 and that actor
vin diesel will be reprising his role as
the beloved god butcher baby groot
because if you don't uh remember uh baby
group killed a god and uh he and gore
have something in common there
and though we don't have an official
time period confirmation yet considering
that groot is a rebellious teenager by
the time of avengers infinity war and
according to marvel themselves the show
will be following a baby groot's glory
days growing up and getting into trouble
among the stars i'm willing to bet that
this show will likely be centered around
root's perspective as his parents rocket
peter quill gamora mantis nebula and
drax travel the galaxy doing their
guardian ass thing while he just does
tree branch type shenanigans in the
background you know much like his formal
introduction in gardens of the galaxy
vol 2 when baby groot was dancing around
fighting space rodents while the
guardians team fought a giant tentacle
monster from another dimension it's one
of my favorite parts of the movie and i
think that this is what i am groot is
it's just him having adventures on his
own and i believe the reason why i am
groot is a spin-off of the guardian saga
is because the main guardians of the
galaxy story in the live-action movies
is that of family specifically the theme
of family being the one that you choose
whereas i am root though being helmed by
the president of family himself vin
diesel seems to be a project more so
revolving around the early adolescent
years of baby groot and detailing how he
became the sassy independent tree with
much rougher bark than he used to have i
mean
oh wait hey
family is the name of the entire game in
james gunn's guards of the galaxy series
specifically how people from broken and
messed up families can come together to
make an even better one and star-lord
pretty much says as much in the thor
loving thunder teaser trailer when he
talks to the god of thunder about love
remember what i told you
you ever feel lost look into the eyes of
the people that you love
because if you think about it we start
off guardians one with a young peter
quill refusing to accept his mother's
demise and rejecting to hold her hand as
she passed to him accepting gamora's
hand at the end of film to symbolically
bear the burden of his pain before
transitioning to a guardian's 2 where
peter learns that his biological father
was way worse than the father that
literally kidnapped him as a child and
spared him from ego's cruelty and of
course we have gamora and nebula two
women from different planets who share
the same abusive adopted father and then
both finding a family in one another and
as well the guardians team and also drax
the destroying grieving former husband
and father who heals from his massive
loss by bonding with his new guardian's
family and developing an almost fatherly
bond between both baby groot and the
also new to the universe mantis she
really doesn't know how life in the
universe works because ego just kept her
cooped up all that time and of course we
cannot forget about rocket raccoon as he
will of course be the main focus of
guardians of the galaxy vol 3.
specifically detailing the horrific
abusive mistreatment of animals by
rocket's father a creator many are
assuming to be the infamous marvel
villain the high evolutionary guardians
one was all about this sad rabbit
joining a true family for the first time
after losing his only family in adult
groot while the sequel guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 was all about rocket
raccoon's journey of accepting that he'd
even deserve to be part of this new
family in the first place because he's
not as much of a monster as he thinks he
is he didn't chase him away
no even though he yelled at him that was
always mean and he stole batteries he
didn't need well of course not and
speaking of guardians of the galaxy vol
3 adam warlock is another future
guardian of the galaxy with a shitty
parent obsessed with evolving him for
their own selfish purposes just like
rocket raccoon as we last see aisha in
the guardians of the galaxy 2
post-credits scene completely off a
rocker attempting to create a whole ass
living being just for the purposes of
crushing the guardians of the galaxy who
humiliated her so it's a new type of
birthing part man is the next step in
our evolution
more powerful more beautiful
more capable of destroying the guardians
of the galaxy
i think i shall call him
adam and also much like rocket appears
to have at the mcu adam warlock also has
strong ties with the high evolutionary
in the comics viewing the high
evolutionary as sort of a father figure
in the high evolutionary as his perfect
savior of the sun so i can see the
overall theme of family tying in with
these two characters when they
inevitably meet in this movie and
finally we of course gotta talk about
the guardians of the galaxy mvps yondu
and adult roots because both of them
were willing to die for the families
that they made for themselves without a
second of pause or regret because they
both owed their families a massive debt
of gratitude for changing their lives
for the better because without them they
would have nobody which is why adult
groots we are rude at the end of a
guardians of the galaxy one hit so hard
because he finally didn't feel like he
was alone
are
[Music]
but all in all the guardian saga is a
story of healing past family trauma
through the selfless love and connection
of the new families that we choose and
while the im groot series does center
around one of these guardians of the
galaxy specifically this fun little
animated all ages spin-off of a disney
plus show will likely not continue the
theme of healing our emotionally hurt
heroes and instead we merely focused on
healing us the audience during our many
trying times in this cruel world with
the face of the cutest baby tree that we
thought that we'd never see again and
how this cute baby tree finds his own
fun while being the child of these
intergalactic warriors and i for one
cannot wait for the show because let's
be real the brain ain't making the
serotonin like it used to and dancing
baby groot has got the good stuff let me
tell you that but that's it thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
guys are amazing people you can follow
me mastertainment on twitter if you want
to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but more
importantly follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media and make
sure to hit that bell on the bottom of
this video so you can get notifications
every time i upload a video because
we'll be uploading things pretty much
every day and i don't want you to miss
out do not miss out and also if you got
fomo do not miss out on our amazing new
obi-wan kenobi shirt i'm new
rockstarburst.com but again thank you
guys so much for watching this video i
love you guys so much please stay safe
and uh be good to each other i'll see
you guys next time bye
[Music]
you